I've always kind of been hard on my
sleeve kind of guy at least in music not
maybe not in real life but I'm not
scared to say how I'm feeling I'm not
scared to to go into you know deeper
places in my music so that wasn't really
um that it wasn't scary or anything but
I think over the last two years I've
definitely learned a lot about myself
but I've learned how much I love you
know just to just to being a normal guy
a dad I've learned how much I love to to
be in nature I've learned just just
things that make me happy truly
um you know there's there's a lot of
times in in this this life that I live
that you can easily get caught up in all
the hoopla and all the all the that
comes with it but
um for me I just feel like I've learned
what really makes me happy and I think
that's pretty important Morgan Wallen
opening up about expressing himself
through music and making the most of his
platform positive side of the fame
um I mean just I think the biggest one
is just how much you can impact people
with with with your craft and your
products and I don't know if that's
necessarily Fame that's more of you know
what you actually do you know but being
being famous allows you to get your
product to to those people and I think
that that's the the most important thing
and you know being able to start a
foundation or being able to being able
to just touch people I think that's the
the most positive thing
when it comes to being a dad seems
Morgan's two-year-old son plans to
follow in his footsteps my son Andy he
like he he seems like he's more of the
percussion type at the moment I don't
know I think probably probably most most
two and a half year old boys are that
but he uh he carries a pretty good tune
so yeah I say I'd say he at least he has
a shot yeah looks
Luke's appearance on his one night at a
time World Tour yeah Indio come with me
on I don't know exactly what dates or
anything like that but I feel like he's
getting to the point where he's old
enough last tour he was still a little
young and probably wouldn't even have
any clue what's going on but I think now
he's getting to the point to where he
will he will see what's happening and I
definitely want him I'd take him
everywhere I win if I could but you know
obviously he's got to spend time with
his mama too
[Music]